remasters have become an accepted part
of video games in recent years older
games are given a fresh coat of paint
and sometimes even gameplay tweaks and
then released on modern systems
this year alone has seen some pretty big
remasters including Bioshock call of
duty 4 modern warfare and the
elderscrolls v Skyrim but let me ask you
a question
can remasters change too much because
the reality is that these remasters
aren't the same game you played all
those years ago they feature different
textures employed modern-day tech that
simply wasn't possible back then these
aren't upscale transfers of a VHS to
blu-ray these are Star Wars special
editions so what happens when these
updated versions alter too much of the
original art style and gameplay tweaks
that fundamentally make the game
different the Bioshock remaster has been
panned by fans for numerous reasons
including limited graphic options change
to art missing audio and somehow being
even more buggy than the original PC
port but I want to focus on the change
in art because bioshock's art style is
probably its most recognizable aspect
and core to its identity the changes
made in the remaster are pretty subtle
and the average person will probably not
even notice them things like added
seaweed in the bathysphere ride this
statue of Andrew Ryan has been remodeled
that red carpet has been removed and for
some reason the floor tiles in this room
have been rotated the lighting is
different in places and the textures are
less wet which is to say they are no
longer glossy and that feeling of being
in a damp City at the bottom of the
ocean is somewhat diminished and the
truth is a lot of people will not even
notice or care about these small changes
but for some these details are important
because you're playing off of people's
nostalgia and odd changes like the
removal of this carpet for seemingly no
reason other than to just make it
different feels pointless it's like when
George Lucas added this rock in front of
r2d2 it doesn't ruin the movie or
anything but just why but maybe carpet
changes and not wet textures feels too
nitpicky for you how about more obvious
and dramatic changes like the iOS remake
of Final Fantasy 6 for reference here is
the original Final Fantasy 6 for the
Super Nintendo
for the mobile version they stretched
the image then they took the backgrounds
and appear to have traced them over the
character sprites are then completely
replaced everything is given this weird
blurry smudgy effect and then the text
box has been replaced with modern UI
font and a detailed character portrait
the final effect is a combination of
disparate styles that lacks the
cohesiveness of that original pixel art
rather than rebuild the whole game with
a new artistic vision we get this
Frankenstein Photoshop which mistreats
the original art and the artist who made
it
but you won't just see the difference
individuals sometimes remasters add
gameplay changes as well which makes
sense controls and certain mechanics can
quickly become outdated in the
fast-moving world of video games so
wanting to freshen them up for modern
audiences can be a good idea Nintendo's
been doing this with all of their
remasters for the 3d Zelda games
addressing complaints with the originals
and fixing them where they can stuff
like adding the fast sail in Wind Waker
HD to cut down a long sailing time or
changing the song of double time in
Majora's Mask 3ds which lets you skip to
any hour of the day instead of Vanaras
half day these design changes help
remove a lot of the tedium from these
games and all of this is fantastic but
we also need to be careful sometimes in
what we change a video game and its
mechanics are tied to each other and
it's possible to unintentionally alter
the experience too much
such is the case with Doom threes
remaster BFG edition doom 3 has a
controversial flashlight mechanic
because you could not use it and hold a
weapon at the same time this urged a lot
of players leading to the creation of
the infamous duct tape mod so when the
BFG edition came around it made the bold
move of making this mod official
removing the original flashlight
mechanic from the game entirely
it wasn't even available as a menu
option and this is a problem because
even if you didn't like it
doom 3 was designed around that original
flashlight every room was a potential
for a scare and the comfort you would
get from being able to see what the
flashlight came at the cost of being
able to shoot taking that away removes a
large part of the tension and suspense
of doom 3 creates it makes the game
worse
and while doom 3 hasn't aged terribly
well the flashlight is still a unique
idea that you don't see replicated in
other games it's a concept wholly
original to doom 3 and they removed it
but that's ok because we can still load
up and enjoy original doom 3 well that
almost wasn't the case back when doom 3
BFG edition came out original doom 3 and
its expansion were removed from the
steam store no official reason was ever
said for why this happened but if you
want to put on your Cinna cat it could
have been because you could just buy the
original game cheaper and then recreate
all of bf G's improvements with mods the
original game came back to the store a
month later allowing consumers the
choice in which version to buy but this
isn't always the case if you want to
play the horror classic style Hill 2 & 3
which you should your only choice on
modern systems is to buy the HD
remasters which have been heavily
criticized as Rush port jobs that iOS
version of Final Fantasy 6 that's the
version that got ported to Steam and
this is becoming a real issue with games
on digital stores publishers seem
interested in only having one version of
their game on a storefront so if
multiple versions exist they tend to
pick the most recent version a perfect
example of this is the original Resident
Evil Resident Evil One has numerous
ports and updates over the years and
even a full-on excellent remake but if
you still want to play the ps1 classic
it's available digitally on the
PlayStation Store except that's actually
not the original release of the game
it's the Resident Evil
rector's cut DualShock version which was
released over a year after the original
game and features added content such as
arranged mode which swaps around all the
puzzle items it's certainly the most
feature-rich version which is probably
why it's the one on the store but our
EDC DSV also features a completely
different soundtrack from the original
one that is worse but because this is
the only version that got picked to be
preserved digitally that original
soundtrack will eventually be lost to
time and this will be replaced with this
more so than any other media games
change especially in today's era of
updates and patches it's impossible for
someone starting destiny today to be
able to play and experience the original
vanilla release from 2014 it's okay and
even important for games to change and
for devs to be allowed to make those
changes but it's also important to
respect the original versions of these
games and give players choices in the
versions they can play when the original
system shock was finally available
digitally developer night dive Studios
put out the Enhanced Edition which
updated the graphics and improved the
controls a welcome addition because
those original controls were garbage but
it also comes with the classic version
of the game for those that want to
experience it and then there are games
that allow you to switch between
original and updated controls audio and
graphics in the games themselves games
like the Halo anniversaries and the
LucasArts adventure game remasters you
press a button and suddenly you're
swapping between ten years of video game
progress apart from it just being a
really cool gimmick it acts as a
historical showcase and that's what
these remasters should be celebrations
of these games and the time in history
that comes with them which also means
being willing to show the flaws rather
than sweep them under the rug
I want remasters to be the Blade Runner
box set that comes with all five cuts
even if I will never wash the attribute
version because preserving and
respecting games is important and we
could be doing a lot better job at it